foreign
good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of baylor district council
cabinet i'm councillor john ward leader
of baby district castle and i'll be
showing this meeting
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and finally we
will be using e-voting for this meeting
on the modern.gov app so please members
make sure they are logged in and ready
to use the app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and we will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except whether
our confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i'll now move to the agenda so
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councilman vasey thank
you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary other registrable or
non-registerable interests by members
does anyone
council osborne
thank you mr chairman i'm declaring a
non-pecuniary in the cost of living
report an action plan as it does refer
to the ca and i'm a trustee on that
particular board in sudbury
thank you
right moving on to item three oh sorry
castle busby sorry
yeah i guess i probably ought to declare
something others uh director of baber
growth which is promoting the
hq
redevelopment
but i have signed a dispensation form
which hopefully will allow me to speak
i'll ask the monitoring officer to
confirm that please
thank you chair and councillors you need
to refer to the new uh regime of
interest under the new code of conduct
so there isn't a category of uh local
nonprocurement anymore
um councillor busby you have got a
dispensation that allows you to
participate in uh discussions about
their hq sites so you're fine
um councillor osborne if you've got
an other registrable interest or a
non-registerable interest
which you need to disclose that will
prevent you from voting and
participating in the item
sorry so clarification where does that
leave me on that on that particular
report it's just that it it refers to
the ca because they're relevant to the
cost of living crisis so where does that
leave me on that one do i withdraw my
declaration or yes okay sorry mr
chairman i i withdraw that declaration
that's that's okay that's that's
understandable that the um
uh
regulations have changed somewhat and so
we're all getting used to them
okay then that's great thanks so uh
moving on to item three that's paper bca
21 1 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 4th of april 2022
they're on pages 5 to 10
of your agenda pack
so just quickly going through
if anyone can stop me as i go through on
page
five page six
page seven
page eight
page nine
and finally page
ten if no one has any comments may i
have a proposal please
carson osborne thank you and a seconder
counselor arthi thank you
right that's that's great so um we need
to take a vote on that
yes thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
chad that is uh six votes four and one
abstention
thank you
right next item uh is item
four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received chair
item five questions by councillors none
received thank you and item seven
matters referred by the overview of
scrutiny or joint board of the standards
committees there are no matters referred
thank you
item seven the forthcoming decisions
list does any member of the cabinet have
any comments or questions relating to
the forthcoming decisions list
no excellent thank you
right we'll move on to the first
of the main items of of this afternoon's
meeting that's item eight
which is paper bca22
which is our response to national grid's
non-statutory consultation on the east
anglia green overhead line project i'll
now invite the cabinet member for
planning to introduce the report
kasarathi
thank you chairman
yes paper bca22
provides you with the proposed response
you have all attended the briefings as
have many of the affected ward
councillors
and i would like to thank braun curtis
for coordinating those for us she's not
here today so tom barker is maybe you
could pass on please those thanks to
braun for those briefings that she's
done
you will be aware of the concerns
regarding impact on heritage landscape
and quality of life that would affect
our residents and the growing number of
visitors to both baber and mid-suffolk
our overriding preference is for a
coordinated offshore approach to
minimize onshore infrastructure and the
associated impact on our communities and
the environment
subsea cabling options are being
developed for the north of england and
scotland
so why not here
in the absence of a subsea alternative
i'm proposing we object to the current
ea green proposals
mid-suffolk cabinet have already met and
agreed the recommendation to object
and in the strongest possible terms
chairman i move the recommendations in
section three and ask for a seconder
thank you
thank you councilworthy may i have a
second
counselor busby
thank you
i have um also invited ward members to
attend this meeting today to present
their responses to the consultation and
they will be allowed to speak once for
three minutes and this will be timed i
also have councillor carpendale's
written submission
and that's there in your table papers i
will read that out now for anyone uh
viewing this meeting
so this is the response received from
councillor sue carpendale who is uh the
ward member for cable submarine
and she's unable to be present today
i can't offer you any expertise but my
comments reflect my own views and those
of residents in my ward i know that some
of these residents will be making their
own very substantial and well argued
objections direct to the consultation
i am completely supportive of their
objections
i attended the consultation event and
exhibition at holton's mary on the 17th
of may 2022 and requested further
information including a set of maps the
event was busy with many people present
as one might have expected i didn't hear
one positive comment
the proposed corridor for these massive
50 meter pylons passes along the edge of
my ward
needless to say nearby residents are
horrified and alarmed by the prospect
however the proximity of these pilots is
not just an issue for people living
close by
the maps illustrated in 180 kilometer
pylon corridor from norfolk to essex
demonstrate the appalling intrusion into
the area
both visually and in terms of land use
and disturbance
i do not believe that undergrounding a
short section through the aomb is either
sufficient or acceptable given the
impact on the environment including
wildlife and natural habitat
i am highly supportive of the lobby
gaining traction at levels from our
regional mps at westminster through to
local residents that a supply network of
this magnitude should be routed sub-sea
and river in its entirety
if france can ship power to the uk
across the channel the technology
clearly exists
furthermore in view of the number of
power cuts suffered as a result of
weather-related events and in a time of
climate change when there is a
likelihood of more frequent and severe
weather events it surely does not make
sense to erect such an important
long-term and strategically significant
power supply in a manner which will not
guarantee continuity of operation
this proposal is a monstrous imposition
on rural east anglia and dismissive of
alternative supply route technologies
so that was from from councillor
carpendale
what i will do uh first of all i'll ask
members if they have any questions
present and then um if any other members
and i know council hidden probably wants
to say a few words so first of all i'll
go to members of the cabinet does anyone
have any questions on this report as it
stands
before we go into debate
no
okay
um
council hinton would you like to say
something
thank you very much stevens chairman um
yes this proposal is as councillor
carpenter has pointed out in her written
submission uh it's extremely intrusive
across a wide swathe of the countryside
from norfolk all the way down through
into essex
it chomps through the
parts of of my ward and across the star
valley
and it will be extremely intrusive
more intrusive than the existing power
network that is already in place
we know that these networks are
vulnerable
to
weather conditions we saw a few years
ago a lightning strike on a gas-powered
power station in
bedfordshire
that blacked out the whole of northern
east anglia
and ipswich hospital for the simple
reason that it then tripped out a wind
farm so even having wind farms off off
the coast it's not uh
a reliable uh source when there is a
storm around or anything like that
putting
energy that's generated off off this
uh off coast
under under sea
is a logical way to proceed there are
already proposals within this for part
of it to be put under the sea round to
tilbury so why on earth can't the whole
thing be put under sea from the start of
the operation up in
off the north norfolk coast
we know that in the
possible near future
there's going to be a third
nuclear reactor at size well
that will presumably
mean that they're going to have to put
up some more pylons to take the power
from from sideswell to where it's
actually needed
and that will mean further intrusion
upon the coast
the countryside of suffolk and north
essex
we know also that within the plans
i hasten to have to say strategic
thinking that the government has got in
place but it doesn't seem to have an
awful lot of strategic thinking as far
as power generation is concerned
that the new mini nuclear reactors if
they ever get off the ground
will be placed near to where the
electricity is going to be consumed and
that will reduce on transmission costs
and transmission losses so putting
something underground or undersea now
will give positive benefits for the long
term for the whole of east anglia which
at the moment is turning into an
enormous great pylon farm
so i support very much the objections of
the council to
the over grounding of the of the the
pylon erection of these
proposals
thank you councillor hinton
we have a report in front of us which
actually uh tries to achieve and i think
achieves very well two things firstly of
course
um
it it provides a direct response um to
the consultation on on the technical
aspects
of the um proposal which which is uh to
be welcomed because there are certain
um
issues we have with the uh the proposal
as it stands should it eventually go
forward um and there's some useful
suggestions to the changes that can be
made to that but the other thing of
course is
to
express our opposition to this
particular solution when there are other
solutions
available or potentially available
so
any cabinet members would anyone like to
comment on this report
council mccraw
only to say that it's a very complete
report and i don't think there's a
single uh thing that you would want
to be included that has been missed
obviously i'm very pleased to see that
the
biodiversity um for the catawba marshes
has been included
and it could actually easily have been
argued that they that was a distance
away but in fact it's not because so
it's literally
anything that affects the environment is
not just a matter of you've got to be on
the spot a little bit down the road does
matter so i commend the report i think
it's a good response um and i can see
that it was passed successfully by
mid-suffolk i can't see any reason for
us to do anything different
thank you councilman crawl um i actually
have um a couple of um points that i'd
like to to make myself actually on on
the content and some suggested
editions which i've already related to
bronn
um firstly on the recommendations um the
second recommendation um that the
assistant director for planning building
control and collaboration with cabinet
members for planning consider any
proposed amendments
that should also include um the the two
council leaders as the report will
eventually be sent on behalf of susie
and myself
so if we could have that added to the
recommendation
do you want me to comment on that
chairman yeah okay if you will yeah it's
what mid suffolk did they said that
that's um
that the response should be
authorized
for
um tom
um
in consultation with
um the leader as well as the cabinet
member for planning and it would make
sense for us to do exactly the same
so that would be adding
adding you as leader to
the cabinet member bit
uh thank you councillor arthur so as
proposal you're happy with that um
council busby a second are you happy
with that
thank you
um the next point i wanted to make um is
on page 16
of the report
and that that is in the paragraph or
prior to the paragraph that that says in
the absence of greater clarity around
the options
um
and following on from the paragraph
uh referring to the undersea cabling
for the north of england and scotland
um there's an another paragraph that i
wanted to add in between those two which
which states that
when i read it out the councils are
concerned that national grid decided
prior to this consultation to choose a
land route for atnc rather than a viable
undersea route scd-2
there is a lack of transparency about
how why the recommend recommendation for
scd-2 was changed to stop
in noah 2020 to 21 after it had
initially been assessed as viable
this decision should not be made without
public consultation
and just to
add some clarification around that
scd-1 is currently a subsea link between
east anglia and
kent that has been approved
there was going to be
a second undersea route scd-2 to replace
the southern section of east anglia
green the bradford tilbury section
which is known as atnc
that
second route scd-2
was um included in
what national grid called their know
that network um
network
operations assessment or something like
i think that's what it's called um i'll
just clarify that
for a moment
network options assessment
so it was in that
prior to 2020 to 21
but suddenly because it was assessed as
viable but suddenly in 2020 to 21
it was um reclassified as stopped
and there wasn't any real clarity over
that so i think we need to have
a sense or paragraph here to that effect
i don't know what what people think
about that
i don't mind i've been looking at tom
barker um i don't know if you've
provided him with that text ahead of ron
has it have you brought has it brown has
it okay so um if we approve the
recommendation today
tom will be able to add that and
anything else that's necessary to beef
up our response and strengthen our
objection
okay
um
the other thing there was another one
which
i
wanted to
include oh that's right yes um
on page 20
at the bottom of page 21 it talks about
the ceiling and comp the cable ceiling
end compounds
and
looking at um
alternative locations
one clear alternative location for that
for the northern end of the aomb ceiling
compound is the not the enterprise park
at raymond and it might be worth
highlighting that tom
if we could
and i think that's that's it from my
point of view does anyone else have any
comments on this
i am mindful chairman that that comment
is sort of um trying to make an option
that we're not supporting
acceptable
obviously the main thrust of our
objection is that we don't like
the overground
underground would be better but we don't
like that either
and what we want to see is subsea
but um
i
if you're happy to leave that
to tom to agree with braun it'll come
back to you and to me um before it's
sent off
i think that that makes sense but
certainly um i take your point about um
uh indicating that we might find this
acceptable or not but there's lots of
other uh suggestions in the technical uh
response to the consultation that um
uh that this naturally fits in with so
that which is why i suggested it but
we'll look at it and
along with the other things in detail
but in terms of the the overarching
principle that we should be looking at
uh
we
we should be asking national grid
to look at a more strategic offshore
route um and support very much suburna
jenkins offset task force which he has
set up to lobby parliament to that
effect
lobby ministers rather to that effect
that is
clearly what all of us wish to see isn't
it
does anyone the castle busby
yeah i kind of agree with with clive on
the comment i think the danger is once
you start putting in suggestions as to
how they can
improve their overhead lines it almost
implies that you're
resigned to that as an outcome and i
don't think we should be i think we
should be stressing as far as we're
concerned there is only one outcome and
that is
a subsea
we should be resisting every
industrialization of our countryside
that we can
this is not what we're known for it's we
are a rural countryside we're in rural
counties people come to see us the
tourists come to see us for that people
live here because of that they don't
live here because they can be close to a
pylon
and we should resist with all strength
even stronger objections than
thank you castle busby and i think it's
disappointing that bayes and ofgem have
not tasked national grid to look in more
detail and and with with more regard to
uh subsidy options and indeed to join up
all of these
um requirements around the country into
a fully strategic grid off offshore
council macro yeah i'd support
councillor arthi and councillor busby's
point on that
seeming acceptance by proposing an
alternative i think we're better to have
a stronger and more coherent argument
and i'd rather not see us weaken that
argument
okay thank you
if castle osborne
thank you mr chairman um yeah i have
read this and it is rather concerning
and i know many of our residents are
really concerned about this and we do
need to be very robust in our response
and i absolutely agree with councillor
busby um if you make that comment it
does appear that we're supporting the
overhead cables and i don't think that's
the way forward
but otherwise i agree to the
recommendations with the amendments that
have been suggested today and i do hope
that this will help our residents feel a
little bit more assured that we're on to
this as are many others to make sure
that the right approach is taken thank
you mr chen thank you councillor osborne
council mclaren
thank you uh mr sherman yes i just want
to
confirm what my colleagues have said on
the cabinet
i
the think of busbee's comment about
tourism being
one of our major industries and
especially on the east side of baber
and
at the moment tourism is in a poor state
and we don't want people to be put off
from coming to our bit of the world
because we rely on their income and
their support thank you joe
council mccraw
this might be a late technical question
perhaps tom would be able to answer it
but i know this is a non-statutory
pre-application
consultation does that
give a
does it give the national grid more
options fewer options or do they
eventually have to go to a statutory
consultation
just asking
um just yes if they chose to take the
take it to the next stage then that
would be a statutory consultation
so this is essentially a public
pre-application
can i just say chairman i think that
actually reinforces the importance of
getting in early
and saying exactly what we think
rather than sort of beating about the
bush and that is that we want sub c
we don't like overhead we don't like
overhead with bearing of some cables
because that has an impact on our
landscape and our communities as well
what we want is subsea and i think
getting in early with that view saying
that that should be properly explored is
the right way to start
yeah i agree with that and and i think
also that um
this this particular issue does need to
be clarified with a matter of urgency
because at the moment
um there is increasing light caused by
this proposal on many of our residents
because the corridor is quite wide in
places
and a large number of people are
currently
potentially impacted by it in terms of
their their well-being as well as their
their um house price values which
inevitably will get impacted by it
and it's causing a lot of people a lot
of upset and anguish so that this
particular issue must be resolved as
soon as possible to to set their mind
straight
so if there are no further comments by
members of the cabinet then we'll move
to the vote on this please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
thank you that is seven votes for that's
your anonymous jen thank you
okay now moving on the next item is item
nine paper bca223 the cost of living
report and action plan
i'll now invite cabinet member for
communities and wellbeing to introduce
the report report
so uh council mclaren and before council
mclaren speaks i'd just like to remind
everyone that the
the actual report follows on from the uh
the detailed uh papers so uh it's in a
bit of a reverse order today for this
one
council mclaren
mr chairman um i think this is my maiden
speech
i'm not quite sure about that
i don't need to stand thank you very
much that's very kind
i'm very
uh proud to be presenting the cost of
living paper
in recent months members have been
involved in discussions in how the
district should respond to the cost of
living crisis
national and local reports indicate that
the impact is very real for our
residents and our staff and is likely to
become more challenging in the months
ahead
the proposed cost of living five point
plan recognises that focusing on cost of
living issues alone will not mitigate
against the hill health impacts across
our communities and believe a focus on
well-being is also required
therefore as described in the cabinet
report the proposed plan focuses on two
things
number one to provide support and advice
to deal with the cost of living issues
and to make sure
that the government support gets to
those who need it such as household
support grant war
homes discount
and various other grants
we've got to make sure that we exercise
discretion and provide welfare support
and advice to those who actually need it
making best use of the data available to
us and keeping an eye on trends
such as monitoring direct debit
cancellations council tax and rent areas
free school meal numbers and continued
close working with our local
citizens advice service
we must make sure we are aligned with
our partners across suffolk so that we
can continue to influence the system
and the support available
this might also include the development
of campaigns initiatives and incentives
focusing on debt management
energy efficiency and making sure our
residents are aware of support and
grants available to them
and the second part of our focus is to
support people to maintain
and take responsibility for their own
well-being
and at baber this is an area that we
have already invested in
both from
a strategic and a financial perspective
and therefore we are in a good position
to continue our efforts to ensure that
everyone has good health and well-being
we will continue to deliver activities
that focus on maintaining good health
whether that would be referrals for
mental health support
discounts at our gyms and swimming pools
and engaging in community-led wellbeing
initiatives
volunteering and socializing via local
initiatives
we need to look at events that bring
people and communities together that
will support mental health and
well-being
and we need to build community
resilience
we will be as we already do working
alongside communities through our
locality roles encouraging our
communities to engage in as many
positive activities as possible
from
community copper events frailty
programmes to asb initiatives
we will continue to focus on access to
food and nutrition whether that be
participating in healthy eating
exercises and initiatives
organizing a community garden to grow
produce
setting up community pantries or
providing extra support to local food
banks to meet any unmet need
and it's about making sure we encourage
the best use of initiatives such as
holiday activities and food programme
for children during holidays
and ensuring that the free holiday clubs
have a positive impact on children and
young people i'm very impressed with the
family park cooking initiative
one of the programs we are hoping to
explore as part of the plan is the
development of a community leadership
program that will focus on a small
number of pilots to bring people
and stakeholders together
to decide design and deliver local
initiatives
it is important to note that a
significant amount of the activities and
initiatives listed in this five-point
plan are a reflection of all the things
that we in weber have been doing well in
supporting our residents internally and
with partners
therefore the ask in responding to the
crisis not about creating a whole new
set of initiatives
but rather about making systems work
better together
to share intelligence
develop our collective capacities to
respond and act
and
this plan does precisely this
i would also like to write
that i am particularly looking forward
to establishing a cost of living
coordinator
which will continue to build on the
substantial operations we already have
in place
including customer services housing and
welfare support and external
partnerships to ensure that partners are
talking to each other in meeting
people's needs
finally chairman i'd just like to remind
as this is the public meeting
i feel it's important to remind people
what the five-point plan is
it's about coordinating government
support
exercising discretion when providing
welfare support and advice
maximizing partnership working and
established systems to provide targeted
support in localities
and if we are to prevent further crisis
we maintain good health
and make sure that people have access to
good food and nutrition
so mr chairman i'm approving
the recommendations
in the report of 3.1 and 3.2 and i'm
looking for a seconder thank you
thank you castle mclaren thank you
uh secondary councillor crore you wished
a second thank you
uh just wait while
some next people settle in the meeting
yeah thank you councilman this um it is
excellent report we have in front of us
today um so uh
it's been proposed and seconded
does anyone have any questions first of
all
councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman yeah actually i
really welcome this report and the
approach um
i just hope it works in practice as well
as it does in theory that's that's my
concern and i haven't always been a
strong advocate for early intervention
and prevention so i do welcome this my
questions are is can i be assured that
there is going to be no duplication in
this work being done if i could just use
for an example
in the housing team we have already have
a financial inclusion support team where
we provide support across all tenures
not just our own tenants
where we provide support with maximum
benefit charitable gifts applications
for discretionary housing payments food
on fuel vouchers and advice and we're
actually currently recruiting an
additional officer to this team to help
that out so that's one question that
there won't be duplication and the other
one is
can we be assured that this will be
monitored to see the effectiveness of
the approach that we're taking with this
thank you mr chairman
thank you council council mclaren yes
thank you mr chairman yes councillor
osborne i can reassure you that they a
duplication would be a terrible thing
because it would mean many residents
would miss out but
we have
as you know i'm new to this portfolio
and so we're planning on having regular
updates and monitoring throughout the
programme and this is only phase one
this is just the beginning okay but i'm
assured from
we haven't gotten an assistant director
at the moment but the corporate manager
for communities that we will be
monitoring this all the way through the
program okay
yes
thank you councillor in in regards to
the monitoring um what can those reports
come to cabinet on a regular basis
please
i am sure that's possible councillor
osborne
thank you council rafi
yeah i just wanted to agree with
councillor osborne about the monitoring
and the reason for that is that
this is
not so much direct
action from us it's more about support
for for various
other initiatives if you actually look
at the five-point plan
i've picked out the words
coordinating exercising discretion
partnership working
community-led initiatives local
initiatives and providing support so in
a situation like that where we haven't
actually got anything direct that we're
doing that we can measure it's really
really important that we actually
monitor
what we're achieving what we're doing
and where
yeah
thank you guys
and i replied yes
thank you councillor arthur well i can
assure you as a new
cabinet member for this portfolio i am
amazed at what we as a district are
actually doing towards this
some of this sounds about partners and
dissipating the responsibility but i am
so impressed
with what people the the staff that i've
met and what they're doing already in
relation to the nutrition and activity
so i can assure you it will not just be
sort of spread a lot across a lot of
agencies and partners
i think the point that category osborne
was making that i was supporting um was
that it's actually really important to
come back and give us some sort of
feedback on on what we've achieved and
where and how i quite agree chair um we
will be back with regular reports and
i myself will be involved with the
producing those reports thank you
thank you are there any other questions
because we are straining to debate now
so if
if there are no further questions does
anyone wish to
contribute to the debate councillor
busby
well
both both okay in one
um yes i mean it's
great words and i fully support them
um it's the practical aspects that i'm
interested in what we actually can see
we can do and this is really a question
for tom
uh we talked about the community gardens
will it have an impact on
what we can decide on planning
applications if
a developer
puts forward a community garden or not
or if
the
village parish want a community garden
in somewhere and the developer won't
allow that will we have teeth
thank you councillor busby um it would
be i think both of those things would be
material considerations that an officer
through a delegated decision or a
planning committee would be able to have
regard to
quite how sharp your teeth would be
i think would be open to question and
would be need to be weighed in the
balance against other considerations and
plan that approach so
you've already got policies within your
existing planning documents and within
your emerging planning documents that
support this approach
to
open space and
growing of food so you you have some
teeth
as i say how sharp they are compared to
things like
affordable housing or
other infrastructure and those kind of
things as with all planning decisions it
would need to be weighed in the round
thank you
does anyone else wish to make any
comments
um
if not it's just one thing i wanted to
just draw attention to
under the partnership working
uh there's a reference to uh these
suffer public sector leaders and the one
million pounds
funding that we have provided just just
a quick bit of background
this is to cover three things really the
suffolk advice and support service
local welfare support service and food
banks
and there's going to be very detailed
monitoring of that and reporting back on
a regular basis to suffer public sector
leaders as to how that million pounds is
being spent and that all ties in with
very much what we're trying to achieve
here and indeed all of our other
districts and boroughs in the county as
well
does anyone else which council of usb it
kind of going back onto the practical
thing um food banks
do we
and i probably ought to know the answer
to this question do we publicize on our
website the location of all food banks
within our district
if not why not
do we do anything in terms of
going out to food suppliers to try and
encourage them to
donate to these food banks do we have
do the food banks tell us what they're
short of what they need
is this something
a little more practical than saying
we'll be monitoring food banks
i personally don't have answers to those
vicky
are you able to pick up on that
yes thank you for that uh chairman um we
are working very closely with um public
health and there's piece of work like as
you've said already
through public health and community
action stuff like we're looking at
supporting food banks we also have close
contact with our food banks and we're
aware of the relationships they already
have with supermarkets for example who
do donate significantly to the food
banks and from the local food banks
we're in contact with there isn't a
significant issue at the moment with
food supply
but we also know that in public health
they are looking at
rather than supporting food banks
individually there is a a piece of work
taking place to look at how we can
support food banks as a collective in
terms of that support from from the
supermarkets directly into those food
banks so that's been looked at at the
moment but certainly we are already
having those conversations and have been
since early early days of the pandemic
thank you vicky
anything else from anyone
council rafi
yeah i've just had a look on google
and
it would appear that suffolk county
council has a list of food banks in the
county
and it would appear that we've put
something on facebook
about
fork and kitchen deli for free cookery
classes
but other than that i can't actually
find very much so i think councillor
busby's point is a good one
and while i'm talking he was mentioning
um what else would do i think with
regard to planning and i think a fairly
good example of that is communities that
may not have allotments
um
and i've had experience of it in
cockfield where we were able to help
them with
a sill
bid
and they actually bought land and
they're currently establishing
allotments
which is conveniently located to the new
development
of 50 or so houses
so there are things that we can do and
that just goes back to why the
monitoring is so important
because we're not actually buying
ourselves an
allotment and running it for a community
but we are very much involved in the way
that they fund it the way that they
achieve it the way that they secure the
land and so if we're involved in that
it's important that we know what we've
done
because it's not going to show up in our
budget next year
it's it's to do with
a post that's working with communities
to achieve things
and so we need to know what they've
achieved and where
thank you councilman crawl
i've got a number of points a second of
the motion i might want to keep them for
the end of debate
but
in that case if we're going for the end
of the debate
i would just try and sum up a few things
as a seconder unless somebody else
wishes to speak
jen
thank you i think i can perhaps phrase
it as a question i'm not sure um
we've got on the shotley peninsula quite
a lot of village pantries
and i'm sure that the rest of you have
got that sort of thing as well so
it is right down at grassroots level
isn't it that that these things are
happening not necessarily always under
the umbrella of the local the local
authority and so incredibly difficult to
mark all of these small little
food pantries in instead of harkston
delta etc
so a very difficult thing to monitor
and i just want to echo the the course
for robust monitoring
and i suppose my question would be
perhaps one that is maybe in a bit more
detail than we need now but
how are we going to monitor it's all
very well to be given the assurances
that it's going to be a robust monitor
but how is that going to happen
and how are we going to incorporate all
of these little food countries in our
wards there are apps that go on to um
i'm struggling to phrase this as a
question
there are apps where food can be
allocated
and so some kind of is the question
is it possible to have some kind of
advertising and marketing on the website
with the apps as well that aren't
necessarily local authority ones
question about allotments that
councillor arthur just made me think
um pleased that there are more
allotments but we do see a lot of
allotments that actually aren't being
tilled
so possibly is there a way that we can
do some monitoring of this as well and
make sure that all the allotments there
are tilled and being made good use of
thank you
yes council mclaren yeah
yes this
concern about monitoring i think
i
with
um
vicky i've got to set
the
monitoring standards that we want to
achieve
and as this paper has got to be approved
we can start as soon as possible
uh because that's important
that um you are satisfied that i mean
it's back to perhaps overview and
scrutiny would like to take it on uh but
monitoring that
you monitoring us to make sure that
we're doing our job properly and
reaching the needs and of course this is
about people
this is not a theory this is about
meeting the needs of real people out
there in our communities
so all i can do at this stage
is reassure members
that we will
provide evidence of our monitoring
which will be very regular
thank you jeff
thanks for that council mclaren um
before i go to council mccraw just um
what one point i'd like to say myself i
i think what we have here is an action
plan that
is
incredibly comprehensive and i think is
going to
enable us to provide an excellent
response because it doesn't just
look at what what we can alleviate in
terms of helping people through the cost
of living crisis
but
equally we're addressing the prevention
of crisis and that that's far more
important not not just for the uh the
immediate acute problems but also longer
term to allow people to to live um
better lives going forward so i think
this this is going to have a huge impact
beyond just the immediate cost of living
crisis
uh council mccraw did you want to say a
few words before we go to the vote yes
um and i think it's just um just to put
it into summary really because i think
it's important to focus on the fact that
this is a six-month action plan it is
our initial response to a situation
which is likely to change further in the
course of the next 18 months or even
longer we hope it will be 18 months
shall we say
and this is one of the last pieces of
work carried out by nadine before he
left us and i'm sure vicky will be able
to provide me with a background on some
of these things but i think the
important point to note here is that the
six-month time scale
precludes to some extent some of the
points raised in terms of um
involvement of planning at the policy
level we are talking about six months
the time which we do that the chance of
planting allotments within six months or
getting allotments within six months is
also
slightly precluded but this action plan
is building on existing and enhancing
the pre-existing workers referred to by
councillors mclaren and osborne these
programs are in place i know the housing
team for my years of experience on the
council do what they do i know the
communities team have programs already
in place so we are not just
starting from scratch
and we know that and in particular in
point one when it comes to enhancing or
making sure that government support is
maximized and used best well in our
experience of working with covid we know
we can do that because we've done it
very successfully in the past and it's
quite likely that the chancellor is
going to have to introduce
more support and it's quite possible
that he will need to use the district
councils as the means of supplying that
support we are an obvious conduit to to
get money where it's needed because we
are on the ground we know the people who
need it and we're a great deal more
flexible than a national government can
ever be
another couple of points um we talked
about
food banks and
citizens advice were mentioned well i
think that's an important point the
report does refer to the fact that
citizens advice in sudbury and i believe
in ipswich as well
do coordinate
the food bank
availability across
our part of the of the district and
those two cities that we support
financially
um
we are using um we're getting a cost of
living coordinator and obviously i've
heard people say well that's another
officer this is being funded by the
department of leveling up and housing
and whatever else is on the agenda for
the day
um but let's just call it leveling up
and so this is already being funded from
central government we would be foolish
not to take use of it we support
citizens advice there is a natural
synergy with citizens advice i had long
discussions that nadine whilst this was
being prepared we support ca because it
is doing similar jobs to ourselves all
our officers and all our departments
know that
so
i don't think we can argue any more that
this needs to be put through but we have
to bear in mind that this is step one
and the monitoring will come as a
constant evolving process
and then we'll go into step two at the
end of this year and by the i would say
by the end of this year we're likely to
be re-examining this ready for 2023. so
i commend the um recommendation
thank you customer crawl all very valid
points particularly the one about
government using local authorities as a
conduit for
distributing financial support but
covert has certainly proved that local
authorities not only can do it but our
best place to do that um
the success of the financial support
through covert um was primarily to the
down to the fact that local authorities
around the country responded very
quickly and very efficiently so um but
thanks for all the points you raised
if there are no further comments from
anyone then we'll we'll move to the
votes oh sorry council beer
um
thank
we did have questions earlier
i i thought this is where we could
question before you take the vote
um well we move from questions into
debate but i'll take a question now go
on thank you um it's just one question
and observation um in great corner we're
we're setting up a
[Music]
food bank you could call it uh which
myself and others are involved in
getting this up and running and it's not
as straightforward as you think but um
you did say
um that there's
money where available where needed i
think it was your words will it will you
be able to offer any assistance to any
groups that are starting up
in areas
is there an officer that's dedicated to
help in this field
because they have to have
food hygiene checks and things like that
certificates
so there is a lot of involvement and i
think in answer to councillor gold's um
uh question about allotments certainly
in great corner
there's very few allotments that are not
being used so i i think that's another
area where
encouragement should be given but really
i just wanted to know that
you know how do we access some of this
help
thank you council mclaren
thank you council a beer if you leave
that with me i will get back to you
bye thank you
thank you
right
okay
no further questions or points we'll
move to the vote please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that's seven votes for that's unanimous
thank you
next item 10 paper bca224
avayva former headquarters development
site
the cabinet member for assets and
investments is also on the board of
labor growth and consequently i'll be
introducing this report
instead of him
i know we're all keen for the
development of the former hq site in
hadley to commence at the earliest
opportunity after the unavoidable delays
that the project has suffered
and this report sets out how we can
achieve this
the development will provide 57 new
homes and represent a major investment
for hadley
it was important that we took the time
required to find the best possible
solution for the local community and the
neighboring cricket club
but we now find ourselves in a
particularly challenging period of
rapidly increasing costs supply chain
issues and uncertainty within the
construction industry due to a
combination of factors including brexit
the pandemic and the war in ukraine
having considered the options for this
site as presented in today's report
carefully
including a sale alternative schemes and
phasing
i strongly believe that the best way to
ensure that this development is brought
forward is to increase the debt
threshold for vapor growth limited
to deliver the planned high quality
development of phase one
this is not about increasing the bill
for the tax player but purely to do with
cash flow during the phasing of the
project and the governance around the
amount baba growth limited can borrow to
deliver it
ultimately the development is still
expected to break even or even show a
modest profit for the council
with new homes and investment for hadley
but only if we can release the cap to
borrowing that was imposed based on cost
estimates and phasing from four years
ago
current construction market conditions
are such that the decisions need to be
taken enacted upon promptly as prices
will only be held for a limited period
with raw materials and subcontractor
prices changing daily
the current price is fixed until friday
this week
if cabinets support the increase to the
peak debt threshold today baby growth
limited will be able to secure the
contract this week which will enable
works to commence later this summer this
is an important site and one that we
must support and being brought forward
for development at the earliest
opportunity to live to deliver housing
and support the economic prosperity of
hadley
i'm therefore pleased to propose the
recommendations at section 3 of this
report
and i'd like to ask for a second please
councillor oswald thank you
firstly cabinet members does anyone have
any questions on the report in front of
us
no in which case
other members present does anyone have
any questions and i will ask you to make
sure it is just a question please
council beer
thank you mr chairman
um it's to do with the planning side of
it mr chairman um
why has phase one now been split
into phase one and
phase two a
and
phase two b
which we know as the car parking site
area um
is uh now deemed to be in a flooded zone
so saying um
why is all this now suddenly come
forward why have you split them
and
uh
can you go ahead with this without
taking that back to full council
to see whether that's how they want it
all split up
a bit complicated but there's
complicated reading number three i
understand the question um council arthi
do you have any comments from a planning
perspective
or if not then ask emily i don't think
so i mean it's not it's not a planning
issue
i think the question was
why
um have we now effectively got three
phases when previously we had two
and i think emily is probably the best
company to answer that question okay
thanks
thank you councillor beer for that
question so that's fine don't worry and
so in relation to the phases it was
always planned to undertake the
refurbishment work as um phase one and
so that's the refurbishment and
redevelopment of the existing buildings
and for the new build to form um
the second phase we've looked at um
phase two
and we can see there are some advantages
in bringing forward
phase two a
yeah so we can see there are some
advantages in bringing forward phase two
a
at a slightly earlier opportunity than
phase two b
so there hasn't really been a
significant shift in terms of phasing
we always envisage the being two main
phases the one being the redevelopment
and refurbishment of the existing
buildings and the second phase being new
build
what i've said within the report is that
we will review phase two in further
detail as we progress phase one so
that's both phase two a and two b
but probably excuse me two b is the one
that probably will need to be reviewed
in further detail in terms of planning
we have the sufficient planning um
in place to progress phase one um and
phase um
two uh as as currently designed but the
intention is to progress with phase one
which will bring forward the delivery of
those um refurbished redeveloped
buildings
why did you split it
because is is phase two a
now being flooded as well as
phase two b
is that the reason because you split
the
phase one into two parts
and i just want to know is it because
that part is it's a club
area so so there have been some changes
to the flood zone since the original
planning consent was granted we can
deliver the existing planning consent
um
with the changes to the um
flood
zone allocation
we are saying within this report that we
will review phase 2b
and and that will take into account uh
the changes to the
flood zone allocation since the planning
consent was granted there is a
difference between 2a and 2b in terms of
how it's regarded from
a flood perspective
thank you council beer council halt
yeah um as a director of the holding
company
um i was a bit surprised to see the
papers come through with two aeon
because as a director of the holding
company that's the first time i've ever
seen it
so i'm a bit surprised at that
and we've always had phase one and phase
two which has been quite clear
but to suddenly have a phase two a
concerns me as i say as a director of
the whole company i was not aware of
that prior to seeing these papers
it concerns me greatly of the viability
of the whole scheme
the scheme has always been based upon
the two phases in phase two generating
the profit and return for the council of
its investment
what we have now to me
is we put ourselves in a position
where we're up against the wall we're up
against a time frame and we've got to
vote this
rise in the peak threshold through to
enable the contract to be
granted and the scheme to be delivered
what worries me
is that
is there true viability in this scheme
um
without phase two and there's no update
on phase two whatsoever
that i'm aware of in actually coming
forward in the future
we've got no guarantee about that
whatsoever
and
that calls into the viability the whole
scheme
i just find it
concerning
that we are in a time of
huge increases within the building trade
and i can understand the fixed term
being the preferred option
but i do
have concerns over the figures in that
most
estimators that i've spoken to
are looking around about a 30 increase
in costs
we're up against
a possible recession
today there's been comments in the press
about a declining house sales
and even house values and that again
affects greatly the viability of this
scheme
in the if house prices drop and we value
them at a set price
and they go below that again the
viability of this scheme is called into
question
so
my i suppose my question is
why
was the director of the holding company
why was i not aware of phase 2a
that will do for now
okay thanks so that's it's quite a um
a long-winded way of asking that
question but that's that's fine um just
to clarify that the two phases
have always been the
the renovation phase one and the new
build phase two red outline area of
phase one was a complete red outline i
think you'll find phase two a is now
within the original red outline of phase
one
so why is there a change in the delivery
of that small area okay well why was
that why
not included in the phase one as always
was intended it's just the phase two the
new build has been split but i'll let
emily uh clarify all of that again
and so yes just to go back in terms of
the phasing the the faithing was always
to split it into the refurb
of the existing buildings and the the
new build so that's where the phase one
and phase two
um came from
in terms of phase two uh this report is
looking at phase one and seeking to
increase the um the debt threshold to
help deliver phase one phase two
potentially can be broken into two
phases two a and two b but as the report
sets out there needs to be further
assessment and review of the success of
phase one before we make any commitments
in relation to to phase two whether
that's 2a or 2b
so they are two separate sites they
could be split into two separate phases
or they could be delivered as one
complete phase two
and so
it's not set in stone that they will be
delivered as 2a and 2b
but they are physically separate and so
for the purposes of the plan i thought
it might be helpful to see that but also
from a viability perspective and in
relation to the comments that councilor
beer made earlier
they do have a different
flood zone
um
impact and so
we've we've started to look at them in
those two different pieces
and the report also sets out that from a
viability perspective delivering phase
one and phase 2a does produce a
break-even stroke small profit
and position and both both of those
phases are deliverable without any
further
uh
planning uh consents being required so i
thought it might be helpful for
a cabinet and the council to be able to
see that that there is a viable
break-even scheme that can be delivered
whilst there may still be some
outstanding points in relation to
uh phase two b
thank you emily uh council holds again
question what
concerns me emily is that with all the
data that i was provided
at previous meetings
phase one was always turning into a loss
and with all the increasing costs
and the last time i had an update was
december 21
with all the increasing costs i just
find it very concerning that we are now
looking at a small profit
if we rely on house sales
to generate that profit as i said
earlier i do find that quite a concern
that we're going into a
financial problem for the country as a
whole
where we're looking at interest rate
rises
declining house sales declining mortgage
letting
and if we if if we're presuming
to balance the books this is going to
happen xyz on house income
we're going to be left with a with a
heavy loss
um we're probably 800 000 pounds into
this site already with security and
other measures
that have been spent
it's interested in the papers
we're saying if house prices
can't
be maintained to what we think then
we'll absorb them in our housing stock
well that's all very well and good but
we're still not getting a return on that
original investment by doing so
so again the question is are we basing
this on
figures that
that the market is going to deliver or
are we just speculatively putting them
out there
emily
so the viability of schemes is assessed
throughout the
development
programme so the initial viability is
based on cost estimates from qs's
along with
market appraisals
from estate agents etc in terms of what
the sales figures
are likely to generate it's not
something that stays static and both
costs and
receipts can vary the most recent
appraisals that we've had which are
since the figures that you saw in in
december michael have taken into account
the fact that the works have actually
been tendered so we have fixed costs for
the
development of phase one as opposed to
estimated or budgeted costs and as i've
said in in the report we are
anticipating a potentially a small loss
or a break even depending on how much of
the cont development contingency is
required to be spent uh for this project
so
at this point in time we do believe that
phase one will deliver um a break even
maybe a small loss and that phase two
particularly to a will deliver
a profit so overall we're not looking at
this scheme being a really profitable
scheme we're not delivering this scheme
um from a
a financial perspective it being a kind
of commercially viable scheme this
scheme has always been one which has had
a challenging viability
and that was the case back in 2018
um when this course faction was was
first agreed so it is a challenging site
from a viability perspective and but
that's probably the reason why we as a
council need to be involved in bringing
it forward and because it's unlikely
that a commercial and body would be able
to bring it forward
but at this point in time
we are looking at a break even for phase
one maybe a small loss and so from a
viability perspective yes it's not going
to show a huge profit
but um as it's set out in the uh report
in the appendices there are wider
returns that come back to
the council if we bring this development
forward
thank you emily
one last
question
and my question
does phase one does the profitability
include phase 2a that is clearly shown
on the plan on our papers in front of us
today for the cabinet meeting
no so in the in the papers i'm very
clear that phase one will be either a
break even or a small loss but we're
expecting phase 2a
to deliver a profit
so i don't i think we've been quite
clear within the papers that phase one
is
potentially break even or potentially a
small loss but there's the potential for
that loss to be recapped
through phase two a but that is very
dependent on contingencies if the
contingencies within the
development
appraisal are not needed then uh it
could well be that phase one uh breaks
even or potentially makes a small profit
but at no point in my paperwork that
i've received as the director of the
holding company was too a clearly shown
as a separate deliverable entity it
doesn't need to be shown as a separate
deliverable entity it is part of the
second phase we've split it down but
it's still the same overall um
financial position it's just we've split
2a and 2b into two different
um
this is like cross-examination of an
officer and i mean i don't think that's
the purpose of this session a lot of the
questions that councilor holt has asked
which i i
fully appreciate um why he's asking them
but they could have actually been asked
ahead of this afternoon
we shouldn't have a situation in cabinet
questions where we have an officer being
cross-examined um
excuse me
cancer arthur
certainly not cross examining can
everyone be quiet now please
i've allowed council hall a certain
amount of discretion here because he is
uh um
a director of the holding company
however
we are in questions
and it's questions only so uh the next
person to speak will be councillor
dawson do you have a question and please
make it a question
before cabinet moves into debate
and and the reason being um is because
uh unfortunately congrats to all council
arthur you know as a member of the ward
uh one of the things i would say is is i
none of us
at ward members have really been kept i
i feel like a question please counselor
i feel as if with the questions i'd like
to know why we've more or less sort of
been gagged on this we've had no
information
i wasn't going to ask that question but
i mean if you want to make it into a
question i'm disappointed that we didn't
have more involvement on this project
and had the opportunity to ask questions
so i will ask those now
um
firstly
uh if i i don't know what they should go
to emily or to uh councillor busby but
it is now concerning
there are a number of factors that i
think
new members on the cabinet need to
consider
um who weren't here and when this was
originally brought up six years ago and
the fact is a number of things have
changed since the original decision was
made and one of these for a start um is
the flood risk um you know my concern
about this can you get to a question
please yes i can
could you just give me a bit of leniency
here you're quite happy to others so i'd
appreciate a bit of courtesy myself
the proximity of the site to the river
imposes significant
flood risk constraints and is now in a
flood zone so that being the case how
are we going to deliver 2b if it says at
today's date it's in a flood zone and
we're expecting to use that to make the
profit on one phase one so these members
will not have been made aware of that
when it came up six years ago
okay
can i just just respond to that phase
two a is where the profit is going to be
made we'll be reviewing phase 2b in
terms of the
flood and other assessments emily would
you like to pick up on council dawson's
question please um yes so it is exactly
that so within this report we're looking
to bring forward phase one and that's
why we need to increase the the
threshold
and we have looked at um phase two and
and split it
and we can deliver some of the profit uh
from to a which would mean we've got a
break even or a small
a small profit site and what we've
suggested within this report is that we
look at phase 2b
again as we progress through part of the
development of phase one which will
include looking at the changes to the
heat flood risk in in that area so um i
i agree with you councillor dawson we do
need to review how we deliver phase 2b
but i do think that what this report is
saying is that phase
1
and
2a can be delivered in a viable fashion
2b is in a flood zone and we have this
all with the issue with mccarthy and
stone which is bang next door
if that is in a flood zone which it may
well is most likely and the latest um
modeling has shown that
do you not think that that is the
decision
um that affects
whether we take on this increased loan
threshold if this is not going to be
delivered phase two b
dawson
the the debt threshold is for the
delivery of phase one phase two b is for
the future yes but the point is if
you're expecting to make a profit out of
two a and b no should cover phase one
aren't you because we're not we're get
as she said a number of times we'll
break even or possibly make a loss so
what we we're really hoping here and you
know i more than anyone want to see this
develop so i can assure you um but i
would like to think uh i'm sort of
getting the impression here that the
should be
definitely going to be in a flood zone
and so i'm failing to understand how you
think you could possibly make a profit
the profit is on 2a yes
well and 2b it should be on 2b as well
because you're building four houses
there that is the point it was meant to
be making 450 thousand pounds six years
ago
do you have any other questions okay
council boss
yeah okay we're here ready to discuss
phase phase one
to be we accept there will be there are
issues that have risen because of the
change in flood zones and we will have
to reconsider what we do with that in
the future that shouldn't delay the
decision on phase one we need to get on
with phase one absolutely okay
this development to have something like
this for six years sitting there like
this is is a truly
um
you know quite shocking really um you
know we need to consider a number of
factors right the car park the building
on the bridge lane car park goes against
the long-term vision for hadley as you
know and despite the comments that were
made at the last four council um you
know there is clear evidence in the
streaking strategic parking review which
i undertook hadley as well what is your
question please
as i said in the strategic parking route
hadley has reached the threshold
so to build over an existing car park
with a hundred spaces
um you know the cabinet are they going
to consider the fact that persimmons
plan to remain there for eight years
has that been taken into consideration
by these new members
but that's that's phase two b again i
know what we're here to discuss today
well i know but the fact is focus on the
point of which is phase okay everyone
can you can everyone stop now
council dawson the car park
we the strategic car parking review you
well know does not show that there's a
deficit of parking provision in hadley
and in any respect we're not here to
discuss
phase 2b that site we're here to
no more questions members of the cabinet
questions at my discretion if it's a
question
from your own questions it's very good
we're just going to pause the meeting
okay welcome back to the meeting
everyone sorry for that uh short delay
um we've got uh still one or two more
questions i believe before we go to
cabinet debate councillor dawson you had
two questions
um
in february 2016 carter jones undertook
the initial soft assessment valuation of
the site
and this was followed up with their
employment viability now their appraisal
valued the site at 2.5 to 2.6 on one of
the documents
now should the cabinet are they
considering the informal marketing
advice received in the paper today which
is half a million
or should they be considering the formal
advice
originally by carter jonas because that
we you know which should
they sign we might be better just
selling the site at 2.5 million but i
think from what i'm understanding is
that you seem to think the value of the
property has gone down from 2.5 to half
a million in the last few years
thank you very much
informal advice you've had emily can you
clarify the differences in valuations
i'm happy to come into that as you're
asking the yeah
i do have a voice uh look you're talking
six years ago any evaluation that was
made six years ago is totally irrelevant
today
not necessarily um
the 2.5 i don't know where the 2.5
million comes from but the valuation
would have included the whole a whole
site which would be included to be
the these figures are as accurate as we
can get them given the fact that it's a
fast moving scene in terms of prices
house prices resourcing and uh
everything else that goes with it
for this cabinet paper it says in here
is informal marketing advice of half a
million
and cartage owners did a formal report
so which of those two figures do you
think might be nearer
the truth
the one that's current and the one
rather than the one that's six years old
i mean it's not difficult question is it
you can go down any formal kind of study
that you want it takes time before we
can get the information time is not
something that we have abundance of at
the moment
the longer we wait the more prices go up
the more difficult it is to get a
contractor to
put a tender forward that they're happy
to stick with this is why it's time
limited this is why we need to make the
decision today so that we can sign the
tender for friday so that we can get
started if we don't do that the prices
will go up again and the viability will
get even
worse do you have another question
castle was awesome
the other question i really wanted to
ask was um to do with
do you think we should continue working
with the current partner when they were
originally selected
based on the fact they would be
reasonably quick and would overcome the
necessity for a lengthy procurement
process which has been and bearing in
mind we're putting all the funding in it
has been lengthy it has been costly
do you believe that these are we should
continue with this joint venture group
with this partner
i don't think changing courses in
midstream is is an option at the moment
no definitely not so yes we should
continue
uh within this yeah um
there have been delays we all accept
that and we're not happy with them none
of us are happy with them
it started in 2016.
baby growth weren't set up till 2019 so
three years have passed before we even
got on the case
2019
saw the start of it
and really we kind of got on
on board if you like in autumn of 2019
what happened on 2020 we had
kovit hit us
the discussions with the cricket club
almost were impossible under those
circumstances and that unfortunately
it's only a small factor but it was a
key one which delayed the whole process
by about 18 months
and you're interrupting again
and you're still interrupting counselor
dawson you've had your questions
counselor barrett do you have a question
yeah my question is
uh are the is the cabinet at acting in
an ultraviolet way because i think this
is a financial decision
and i think the uh financial
position of any of the council's
decisions like this of a significant
amount
which is over 25 000
um should really go to full council
where these these budgets were approved
um
and also the um
the amount uh i mean if it was in the
budget heading and it was it was stayed
within a budget heading then yes that
can be done but these figures are going
across budget headings because they're
not covered so that within the
capital programme there's a budget
heading for the old
headquarters building there is also a
capital project
for regeneration
and there's also
one for just capital expenditure general
you are requiring to go into the
regeneration fund which was specifically
set up by emily attack
for the hamilton road project and that
hamilton road project is also coming
forward and that amount of money is
being used for that
so
really you should be going back to full
council for this and it's not a cabinet
decision
because it's a financial one a fiscal
one
also the fact that this is upping the
exposure to the council to a third party
is also dubious as well because the
growth company which is where you're
loaning the money to will be a partner
within the is a third party
so i would say that you are on slightly
dodgy ground
um in actually going down this road
without going to full council
that's my question
thank you casper i will let the
monitoring officer respond to to that uh
as you're referring to the competence of
the cabinet versus uh requiring the
council to make a decision but just one
point the regeneration fund in the
budget is not specifically for hamilton
road um i think you'll find uh emily
would you like to respond to council
back i think you'll find it is actually
thank you chairman um
the uh this decision is an executive
decision so therefore falls within the
cabinet's remit um the cabinet is not
restricted in terms of making financial
decisions i there is no limit to the
financial decision that the cabinet can
make other than that it must be within
agreed budgets and the budget is
obviously set by the full council
the section 151 officer has confirmed
that the funding for this is in the
agreed budget and therefore the cabinet
can make this decision the only
financial constraint that relates to
cabinet decision making is the 150 000
pounds key decision threshold limit
which is another part of our executive
decision-making process procedures but
it's fine to proceed at cabinet with
this decision chair thank you emily
did you have a supplementary question
fact is which i think is slightly
worrying is the fact that because this
is a grounds for urgency it then becomes
that the o f uh over the security
committee cannot call that in again i
think this is slightly worrying of the
way that this cabinet is going forward
without scrutiny
um that that wasn't a question that's
more of a statement i know it was yes
and but uh you are i know you're well
aware that the
um the time constraints we've got on
this and that if we don't get um an
agreement by friday then we're back to
square one with escalating costs so this
is all being done to to keep uh control
on the on those costs and to make sure
that we we have uh something that we can
proceed with finally for this site okay
we've now finished with questions we're
into cabinet debate
do any members of the cabinet wish to
comment on the paper in front of us we
have six options um we've extended the
number of options and looking at others
so we've got a fully comprehensive list
of options
here
in terms of what to do
and that the recommendation clearly is
option two to increase the peak debt
threshold
the thing that we cannot do
is essentially
option four do nothing
for all sorts of reasons not least of
which um the reference earlier about uh
security costs we do nothing those will
just continue to escalate
but um doing nothing is is no good for
our reputation as a council it's no good
for this site it's also no good for
hadley
the people of hadley
are always asking me and indeed the
people of neighboring villages which i
represent when are we going to get on
with it
they want to see something done
they know what we're proposing they know
we're proposing a really good housing
development
and uh that is what they want to see and
they want to see it as soon as possible
they are appreciative of all of the
uh the problems we've we've
been experiencing but
um
now is the time to make the final
decision and go ahead and deliver on
this site
castle mccraw
well just to open the debates chair the
only option that is consistent with the
decisions made in september 2016 by the
full council
by the april the 2017th executive
committee some members
of that committee are present here today
and the 2018 baby cabinet and council in
setting up baba growth although it
wasn't known as that at the time it was
known as a commercial joint venture
vehicle
and agreed the previous peak debt loan
facility this motion part two proposes
to increase that
peak debt loan facility in discussions
prior to this
i've directly asked financial officers
that to make sure that we have the head
room to be able to afford and manage
that debt within council budgets they
confirmed that that was the case the
only option that is consistent with the
council's wishes in the past as
expressed in numerous votes would be
option two so if it hasn't already been
proposed i'd like to propose that option
two
as recommended here and three 3.1 and
3.2
be adopted so that we can get on with
this by friday
thank you castle mccraw does anyone else
wish to make any comments on this
council busby
yeah look
i'm the last person that would like to
continue with
a project or a decision that was wrong
if we made the decision the wrong
decision in the first place then i think
the sooner you recognize it and come up
with the right decision the better
but
the decision was made and we have
progressed along those lines
uh it was always based on housing
until we spoke at the holding company
board not long ago and michael suggested
that we ought to look at a split phasing
of it in terms of housing and
business i liked the idea of that we
looked into that unfortunately it comes
out as uh even
worse position than
using it all for housing the objective
of
labor growth and this project hasn't
changed from day one
it's to deliver
a good quality if not a very good
quality housing development for the
benefit of hadley
and to maximize the profits stroke
minimize the losses
for baber
that hasn't changed it's the same in
2016 2019 and 2022
the method of delivering that those two
objectives might have changed
the world is a significantly different
place now than it was three years ago
the danger is if we don't do something
now it'll be significantly different in
12 months time and will be even worse
off
this is just a case of timing that's all
this is and we need to get on with it
thank you council busby and and we are
in
an unfortunate situation in that it is a
complex site there are listed buildings
there
there are a number of other challenges
unlike our colleagues in mid-suffolk who
were able to redevelop their former
headquarters building quite quite easily
because it was a far far less
challenging site to do
any of councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman um actually
councillor busby has said it very well
and put it in plain facts for us to
understand and for people listening to
this meeting to understand it as well
what i will add to that is this cabinet
do not make decisions likely they look
at all the facts they look at their
reports
they take into information that the
officers are given to us and
we as i say we it's been alluded to that
perhaps we don't do that and as in
regards to new members on the cabinet i
think that's undermining their
intelligence
they're quite able to make those
decisions so um yeah i fully support the
recommendations
in conflict to what they agree on the
other side of the of the chamber i think
the discussion today hasn't actually the
questions haven't added to the debate
they've deflected from it
by 100 degrees so i certainly support
the recommendations
thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor osborne
so i think interestingly
i accept the questions and some of them
were very valid
but you've not come up with an
alternative which
is viable
i think
we won't we're not this is this is
six years to come
counsellors please please
calm down
calm down
we've got
six options we've looked at these all
the possible options um we've focused
and come down on the only viable option
here
council of gold
thank you um as as a new member of
cabinet um i would like to say that i
fully appreciate that there's history to
this and the historic figures
and
perhaps baggage that's gone before
i can only say from where i'm sitting
that i have been thoroughly supported by
emily and the other officers
i've been thoroughly supported on this
particular issue by the briefings we've
had
by the advice and support of my
slightly longer in the tooth cabinet
colleagues
and i am very very familiar with looking
at budgets of over a million pounds i'm
very very familiar journey down into
reports court reports all sorts of
reports i'm very familiar with analyzing
data
and i feel thoroughly supported and do
not have a problem um with this report
as it stands and thank you to emily for
all you have done
thank you thank you
council mclaren yes thank you chair
well i too need to speak as a new
cabinet member
i've been very impressed with the
information but yes
but like counselor gold i've come into
this late into this discussion late
i don't understand the history of it
but i too
come from a background that understands
budgets
um
of a lot more than a million and so i'm
happy to go with the recommendation
thank you
if nobody wishes to say anything
counselor arthi
well
i'll just say
one little thing and um
that is i don't know if councillor
dawson um remembers but long-standing
hadley residents
will doubtless remember the future of
east house
being uncertain for 20 years or so
and we don't want that to happen again
no
we don't and that has um
right okay then we'll now move to the
vote please on this item
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
disappointing you weren't here for the
cost of living
chair that is seven votes for that's
unanimous thank you
that brings today's meeting to a close
the next meetings um and i distressed
meetings are scheduled for the 5th of
july at 9 30 and the 8th of july at 1pm
we've had to split into two due to the
large agenda but i think everyone
and
see you at the next meeting next month
thank you
you